neither does Dana White the New England
native joining us we have the
featherweight championship this Saturday
UFC president Dana White he joins us on
the program Dana you still a Patriots
fan I am a Patriots fan yeah I'll be a
for life but I'm not gonna lie I'm a
little interested in what's going on
down to Florida now too because I'm such
a huge Brady fan and drunk so I'll be
I'll be following two teams this year
how much that hurt though when you
realize Brady was leaving town oh yeah I
think I think it hurt everybody you know
it's one of those things where a guy
who's brought so much enjoyment and fun
and you know a lot of incredible sundaes
over the last 10 years thanks to him and
you'd like to see him retire in New
England but didn't work did you think
you had a chance of talking him into
going to the Raiders I did I think that
he was very interested in the Raiders
okay but that's hey that's none of my
business
that's none of my business yeah but
you're you're kind of the conduit you're
the liaison there you were the power
broker there that Tom here's Mark Davis
we got the Raiders in Vegas how do we
make this work apparently I wasn't if
somebody didn't realize what had
happened the last two months with UFC
how would you sum up the last two months
for your sport you know if spawning me
saying this if you look at where we came
from no television no pay-per-view all
the things when we started not
sanctioned by any state to say that the
last two months has been probably the
hardest two months of my career it was
pretty hilarious but you know I always
believed that we could pull this thing
off we could do it and we could do it
safely and now I don't know the number
I've thought my head but I'm going into
my fifth or sixth fight this Saturday
during a pandemic and you know all the
other things that are going on in the
world right now
we're moving cranking but what was the
biggest hurdle through the last two
months you know I have been getting
blasted by the media and when I say that
you know being blasted by the media
these guys were literally trying to do
everything in their power to make these
events not happen from calling athletic
commissions to politicians to venues you
know you name it you know people did not
when I say people I mean media did not
want this event to happen and you know I
think I pissed off a lot of people when
I made it happen but not your fans and
then oh you care if all I care about
yeah exactly not my fans not my fighters
and not my employees so that's the only
group of people I'm concerned with how
many times have you been tested for
coronavirus so today - today after today
and tomorrow all have been tested seven
times for Koba 19 and six antibody tests
any positives no positives how many
fighters have tested positive - well
that we've tested we've tested out of
all the fighters that we've tested one
but there was another fighter out of New
York who had tested positive on his own
and had no problems
did you actually look at buying an
island are you still looking at buying
an island no we do we have fight island
the infrastructure is coming together
probably in the next week I'll start
releasing pictures of fight Island yeah
because when you look at our business
Deana I started looking at all the
problems we're probably gonna have and
as this thing started to escalate and
get crazier crazyer the number one
problem is and will be for a while is
getting people in from other countries
and we are a global business we have
fighters from all over the world and I
can't keep putting on fights in the
United States without having
international flights or I'm gonna I'm
gonna smoke through all of my talent in
the US
so we're looking at like I think it's
June June 27th will probably be our
first fight on fight island why don't
you just have a resort like a UFC resort
times a tough you know this thing will
be nice it will make do and it would you
know these guys will have a place where
they can come from in from all over the
world and it will be safe and these guys
will be able to compete and they'll be
able to make a look if John Jones had
stayed out of trouble let's say that
last six seven years would would he be
the face of still be the face of UFC you
know you would think so you know at the
time when you look at John Jones at one
point in his career on his trunks on one
side he had Nike on the other side he
had Gatorade you know and I I truly
believe that he is the greatest of all
time and imagine if John Jones have been
doing the right things outside of the
Octagon training getting better all the
stuff he is such a freak of nature and
such a good athlete God knows what he
could have accomplished I think very
highly of LeBron James I'm a Celtics fan
but you can't not like jala Bron James
and you cannot deny the work ethic that
this guy has all the good things that
he's done when he goes on to a team he
raises the level of all the players and
he wins championships or he gets you
close and I think that when I say that
John Jones could have been the LeBron
James of the sport it is the ultimate
compliment yeah can you work together
anymore yes
oh absolutely listen this isn't our
first falling-out and it definitely will
not be our last
did you ever want to fight Conor
McGregor did I want to fight them like
out of the ring I'm 50 years old I don't
know but did you ever get angry enough
where you just might be on a treadmill
every day
these guys no no listen you know I have
600 and something alpha male and females
under contract we're gonna butt heads
and there's gonna be problems and things
are gonna happen but at the end of the
day I have the utmost respect for these
guys and girls and how hard they train
and what they do and believe me the last
thing I'm looking to do is fight any of
these guys
what about Glaser you against will you
tell the story of why you left Boston
yeah so I was I was doing I was in the
boxing business back there and to make
ends meet me and me and my partner used
to train you know executives anybody the
one who learn how to box and we had a
nice little business going and I was
teaching a class one day at one of the
local health clubs and these two guys
walked in right in the middle of my
class and asked me we need to talk to
you outside like I'm in the middle of a
class I was thinking who the hell are
these guys are they with the club or
whatever so yeah they're pretty adamant
that we needed to talk so we went out
into the hallway and I figured out who
they were and you know basically they
wanted money I got a call one day this
is the mob yes the mob I got a call one
day I I they wanted like 1500 bucks from
the 2500 bucks whatever the number was I
don't remember but you know at that time
might as well might as well have been
$25,000 to me and you know I ignored it
and hoped it would go away and one day I
was at my apartment and I got a call
saying you know you got till tomorrow at
one o'clock to pay us I said or what and
I said are you gonna find out I
literally hung up the phone picked it
back up and called Delta and got a
one-way ticket did you ever hear from
these guys they never went to Vegas no
so what happened was you know a few
months after that is when all the stuff
went
and they started digging up bodies down
at the beach and you know why do you
bald your fled and you know all that
stuff happened you know a few months
after I left you ever come in contact
with Whitey Bulger no never did that's
probably a good thing yeah no it's great
thing or as guys any of those guys so
yeah no it's all good the fight this
weekend you want to give the the plug
here yeah I mean there's first of all
stack card tons of great fights and at
the end of the day when you tune in for
a sporting event and especially a fight
you want a couple of those moments where
you jump out of the chair you know look
at everybody and everybody's going crazy
we have a few of those fights on here
and obviously the main event Amanda
Nunez versus uh Felicia Spencer
Amanda Nunez has beat the who's who of
mixed martial arts she is the greatest
female fighter of all time and one of
the greatest mixed martial artists of
all time it is fun to see her work and
she doesn't just win she finishes people
so great main event but this isn't even
she's Ronda Rousey's not even in her
League well she fought Ronda yeah you
know Ronda Ronda was the woman that made
everything blow up Ronda Rousey showed
the world that women can fight and women
can sell tickets and women can make as
much money as men Ronda Rousey was to
pioneer that blew the whole lid off this
thing and then you know you had all
these women that were unbelievable in
all these different weight classes these
women that are unbelievable and people
love to watch the women fight Amanda
Nunez has beat them all and beat them
all convincingly and you know she's the
best ever do it when you saw Holly Holm
take out Ronda Rousey would you think it
was crazy it was we were in a stadium in
in Australia and the fight was so hot
everybody was saying that Holly Holm had
no chance that she couldn't win so it
was one of those shocked the world
moments and Holly Holm became incredibly
famous after that fight yeah I always
wondered that if you're a promoter and
you see one of your stars go down now I
know that means another star steps up
but this is Ronda Rousey and you're
looking at what that means for the box
office yeah well
actually eventually you know every star
ends up going away whether it's here in
NBA or NFL but I was very close to Ronda
Rousey to have an amazing relationship
with her we're close friends so the
weird thing about this business is you
become close to these kids and then
you've watched them fight and you know
many many times there's two people
fighting that you really care about and
it's it's uh it's crazy business but you
know but Danny was wondering about this
where you know you can see where like a
fighters soul is taken you know felt
like Ronda Rousey when she lost she lost
more than just a fight did did you sense
that well what happens is and especially
for somebody like Ronda Rousey who you
know blew the lid off this whole thing
and literally changed the game for women
she was under tremendous pressure 24/7
the media started to get to her the the
you know the pressure of continuing to
fight and win and win and win and win
she's trying to do movie she was trying
to you know create her own TV show she
had shed a lot on the plate and you know
it gets to be a lot yeah I just I just
wondered about that where you know I've
seen where guys lose a fight the boxers
and you just see it it's like they just
don't want to do they lose more than
just a about they lose more than just a
fight there's something that's like I
always thought Tyson when he lost in in
to Buster Douglas he lost more than just
a fight that night he lost his
invincibility and it felt like that
Ronda lost her invincibility because we
didn't think that she could lose right
yeah no I totally understand that but
sometimes when that happens and somebody
loses like that and they disappear and
they go away Ronda Rousey went right to
the WWE killed it over there became a
huge superstar for them and she's
continuing to do things so I don't know
if that was the case as much as I think
the mounting tremendous about a pressure
you know yeah that Natalie wiped her out
amazing run there Dana good to talk to
you have fun this this weekend and we
appreciate your time and you know I
would look into that fight Island
Retreat
don't be great you know you could have
fun rides there I could stay in the
MacGregor Conor McGregor suite you know
we could come up with some things tap
out restaurant I think we're good I mean
we got I got it I got it Dana
oh my god let's talk Thank You Dana
that's it buddy have a great weekend
that's Dana White UFC president